Guys, did you know that intro doesn't stand for introduction? What does it stand for? We'll go ahead. You got the first. What does the I stand for? The I stands for definitely international. Oh, I thought it stands for entertainment. I'm not familiar with the word entertainment, but sure.
伙计们，你们知道吗，intro（引言/片头）并不代表 introduction 吗？那它代表什么呢？我们继续。你先说。I 代表什么？I 绝对代表国际（international）。哦，我以为它代表娱乐（entertainment）。我对娱乐这个词不太熟悉，不过好吧。
I'll entertain the idea. Oh, it's entertainment that starts from the inside out. It's different than entertainment. Okay, what's the end? Entertainment enters you. Entertainment starts from the inside. You push it out. Right.
我来附和一下这个想法。哦，这是由内而外开始的娱乐。它和娱乐不同。好吧，那 end 是什么？娱乐进入你。娱乐从内部开始。你把它推出来。没错。
What are you doing? We have all the content inside of us. We're about to share with the audience. What's the other letters? Oh, I don't have that. Welcome to smart list. Smart. Smart.
你在干什么？我们体内有所有的内容。我们准备和观众分享。其他的字母是什么？哦，我没有那个。欢迎来到 smart list。Smart。
Smart. Smart. Smart. Smart. Smart. Smart. Smart. Smart.
Smart。Smart。Smart。Smart。Smart。Smart。Smart。Smart。
Smart. Smart. Smart. Smart. Smart. Smart. You cook there. Believe me.
Smart。Smart。Smart。Smart。Smart。Smart。你在那开火呢。相信我。
You cook there. Sweet kostume will be on time. We are on time with William &爸. Sweet cent manual. Sweet stomach will be going on. WeOnTime. Sweet sweet William & HUD is now two minutes late. He was one minute late and I just stopped you from texting him.
你在那开火呢。Sweet kostume 将会准时。我们和威廉老爸很准时。Sweet cent manual。Sweet stomach 将要进行。WeOnTime。甜美的威廉与 HUD 现在迟到了两分钟。他迟到了一分钟，我刚刚阻止你给他发短信。
And you stopped making him Almost rude. You can't text and wait until the guy's three minutes late. He made it. He made it two minutes. It's like, that's totally acceptable. Right. He just has to apologize to your guest and we'll be fine. Okay.
而你阻止了让他几乎变得无礼。你不能发短信，然后等到人家迟到三分钟。他赶上了。他赶上了两分钟。这就像，这完全是可以接受的。对吧。他只需要向你的嘉宾道个歉，我们就没事了。好吧。
What's not late enough? What I mean is like, what's the appropriate time to text somebody if they're late? Five minutes is a five minute grace period. Okay. You know, before you get, you know, cause otherwise it's just, it's a little kind of old man-ish.
什么叫还不够迟？我的意思是，如果有人迟到，发短信的合适时间是什么时候？五分钟是一个五分钟的宽限期。好吧。你知道的，在你开始……你知道的，因为否则的话，那就有点老派了。
All right. All right. Have you met me? Yes, I'm here. Hi, Will. I will. Did I miss, I mean, I'm not late. Guys, do I have a story for you
好吧。好吧。你见过我吗？是的，我在这。嗨，威尔。我会的。我错过了吗？我是说，我没有迟到。伙计们，我有一个故事要讲给你们听。
that just happened to be about half an hour ago? Oh, God, I'm trying to hate when you're prepared. No, I'm not. This is literally happened to be a half hour ago. This is unbelievable. Well, we'll see. Well, let us decide. So, you know how I'm on the East coast?
刚好发生在大概半小时前。哦，天哪，我讨厌你准备好的时候。不，我没有。这真的是半小时前发生的。这简直难以置信。好吧，我们走着瞧。好吧，让我们来决定。所以，你知道我在东海岸吧？
I do. Scotty and I haven't vacationed in a long time. We plan this whole thing, blah, blah, blah, blah. Here in New York, gonna go visit Will on Tuesday, gonna drive, go to Virginia to see Scotty's hometown. And then we're gonna go, and then I plan to go to NASA in Florida. You all know this, right?
我知道。我和斯科蒂已经很久没有度假了。我们计划了整个事情，巴拉巴拉巴拉。在纽约，星期二要去拜访威尔，开车去弗吉尼亚看斯科蒂的家乡。然后我们要去，接着我计划去佛罗里达州的美国宇航局（NASA）。你们都知道这个，对吧？
Yeah. So I've been DMing with Jessica Meir, our friend and guest. It always sounds dirty when I hear somebody say that. DMing? Yeah. So our friend Jessica Meir who's been on the show, the astronaut, she, we've been messaging. I'll just say, I won't say DMing.
对。所以我一直在和杰西卡·梅尔（Jessica Meir）发私信（DM），我们的朋友兼嘉宾。每当我听到有人这么说，总觉得有点色情。发私信？对。所以我们的朋友杰西卡·梅尔上过这个节目，那个宇航员，她，我们一直在发消息。我直接说吧，我不用 DM 这个词。
Thank you. And back and forth, like a ton organizing this. Like she's like, okay, I'm gonna get meet you guys here. We're gonna take you here. And all of a sudden she was like, who's this? Yeah. So not like twice, like maybe like 50 times we've been messaging, like trying to figure out
谢谢。来来回回，像是在组织这事。就像她说的，好的，我要去这里接你们。我们要带你们去那。突然她就说，这是谁？对。所以不是两次，大概有 50 次我们在发消息，试图弄清楚。
the logistics of all of this tour we're gonna get. And by the way, a dream of mine forever. How about a half hour ago, my assistant goes, I was helping, he was helping me book the hotel. Hashtag related. And I said, he goes, I just talked to a person at NASA. They said, the hotel that we booked for you is nowhere near the facility.
我们即将进行的这次旅行的后勤安排。顺便说一句，这是我永远的梦想。半小时前，我的助理说，我在帮忙，他在帮我订酒店。话题相关。我说，他刚和 NASA 的一个人谈过。他们说，我们为你订的酒店离设施十万八千里。
And I go, well, how far away is it? And he goes, Texas. Oh, so your assistant thought you were going time. He thinks you're coming to Houston. Yeah, Houston, this entire time I, the idiot, was like, didn't even bother asking her, like, where am I going? I booked the flight. Like everything's booked in Florida.
我说，那离得有多远？他说，德克萨斯州。哦，所以你的助理以为你要去……他以为你要去休斯顿。对，休斯顿，这期间我这个笨蛋，竟然都没问她，我到底要去哪？我订了机票。就像佛罗里达州的一切都订好了。
Why did I think NASA was in Florida? And she just assumed. But Sean, Sean, Sean, did you just go like, tell the guy we want to go to Cape Canaveral? Yeah, I thought that. You didn't go like, hey, before you booked to go. So we're locked. What's the closest airport?
为什么我会以为 NASA 在佛罗里达？而她也默认了。但是肖恩，肖恩，肖恩，你刚才是不是对那家伙说，我们想去卡纳维拉尔角？对，我当时那么想的。你难道没有说，嘿，在你预订之前。所以我们已经定好了。最近的机场是哪个？
Where should I fly into? I know, I know. I just, I don't know what happened. So wait, what is the name of the facility that's in Texas? The Kennedy Space Center. Oh, I'm sorry, in Texas, that's in Florida. In Texas, it's, I don't know, it's the NASA, whatever. Is that Cape Canaveral in Texas?
我应该飞到哪里？我知道，我知道。我只是，我不知道发生了什么。等等，德克萨斯州那个设施叫什么名字？肯尼迪航天中心。哦，对不起，在德克萨斯州，那是 在佛罗里达。在德克萨斯州，那是，我不知道，那是 NASA，随便什么。德克萨斯州有卡纳维拉尔角吗？
No, Cape Canaveral is in Florida. Boy, this is dumb, smart guy. We are smart. This is why we're not rocket science scientists guys. You can't even say that. This is why we're not rocket science, is the quote that we're putting on your grave. So does Jesse Mir, does she end up,
不，卡纳维拉尔角在佛罗里达。天哪，这个聪明人真蠢。我们很聪明。这就是为什么我们不是火箭科学家的原因，伙计们。你甚至不能这么说。这就是为什么我们不是火箭科学，这是我们要刻在你墓碑上的名言。所以杰西·米尔，她最后，
is she going to accommodate your dumbness by meeting you in Florida? No, she's not going to go to Florida. I'm going to Dallas. No, truly? I mean, for you Houston, I'm going to Houston. Good God. Now were you able to rejigger your whole thing
她会通过在佛罗里达与你见面来迁就你的愚蠢吗？不，她不会去佛罗里达。我要去达拉斯。不，真的吗？我是说，对你来说是休斯顿，我要去休斯顿。天哪。那你现在能重新调整你的整个行程，
so that you could go there? Yeah, I'm working on it. Wait, wait, wait, so sorry. So you were all set to get a tour of the Florida space area. And now you're going to pivot everything and tour the Texas space area. Because that's where sweet, sweet Jesse Mir is.
以便你能去那里吗？对，我正在处理。等等，等等，等等，所以抱歉。所以你本已准备好去参观佛罗里达太空区。现在你要把一切都转向去参观德克萨斯太空区。因为甜心杰西·米尔在那里。
Yes, I just, I think I just booked a hotel near the Kennedy Space Center. Anyway, I got to redo the whole thing. Non-refundable. Yeah. Okay, well from what I understand though, the Texas NASA thing is for reentry. That's, so as soon as the rockets take off in Florida,
是的，我只是，我想我刚刚在肯尼迪航天中心附近订了一家酒店。不管怎样，我得把整个行程重新弄一遍。不退款。好吧。好吧，据我所知，德克萨斯州的 NASA 设施是用于重返大气层的。那是，所以一当火箭在佛罗里达起飞，
they shut down, all those guys go to lunch and Houston takes over. Well, Sean's going to be excited about that then. Yeah. Reentry, sorry. I wouldn't get too bummed out about that either. But wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, Sean, Sean, Sean, Sean.
它们关闭后，所有那些家伙就去吃午饭，然后休斯顿接管。那肖恩对此会很兴奋咯。对。重返大气层，抱歉。我也不会对这个太沮丧的。但是等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，肖恩，肖恩，肖恩，肖恩。
Can you believe that? Wait, I can't believe it. But now, because I'm just thinking, because I know the logistics of your trip and so does Jason, that you're coming out here and then you're going down to Scotty's home and then you're going, you were going to go further south and then go meet JB and those guys in that other place.
你敢相信吗？等等，我简直不敢相信。但现在，因为我在想，因为我知道你的行程安排，杰森也知道，你要来这里，然后你要去斯科蒂的家，然后你要去，你本来要往更南边去，然后去那个地方见 JB 和他们。
Right. So now you got to kind of zigzag over to Texas. I got to go to Texas and then back down. This better not come out of my time with you. I know, it's a lot of extra money that I wasn't prepared to spend. Well, you're spending it. Well, yeah.
没错。所以现在你得之字形绕路去德克萨斯。我得去德克萨斯，然后再回来。这最好别占用我和你在一起的时间。我知道，这花了很多我没有准备好花的额外费用。好吧，反正你在花。好吧，是的。
By the way guys, can I borrow $800,000? Oh no. Oh no, he's in too deep. I hope you're not underwhelmed with the NASA tour. I know, me too. I don't think I'm going to be. It's like, I've always, always, always wanted to do it. What are you hoping to see there, Sean?
顺便问一下伙计们，我能借 80 万美元吗？哦，不。哦，不，他陷得太深了。我希望你对 NASA 的参观不会感到失望。我知道，我也是。我觉得我不会。这就像，我一直、一直、一直都想去。你希望在那里看到什么，肖恩？
Yeah, I mean, honestly, for me, I'm like, I could read about it in a book and be like, great, thanks. I'm good. Yeah. Are you think you're going to see something take off? You think you're pushing a button? Yeah.
是的，我的意思是，老实说，对我来说，我宁愿在书里读到它，然后说：太好了，谢谢。我很好。是的。你觉得自己会看到发射吗？你觉得自己是在按按钮吗？是的。
You're going to look at like a launch facility. That's it. No, I'm going to go to the office. Maybe, maybe I'll see how they get in the water and they train in the water. Maybe I could jump down there with them. No guy. You need to go with Will to,
你打算看一个发射设施。就这样。不，我要去办公室。也许，也许我会看到他们是如何进入水中并在水中训练的。也许我可以和他们一起跳下去。不，伙计。你需要和威尔一起去，
Will went to space camp with Chris Pratt, right? I did. We went to that in Alabama. You did? Yeah. Was that was some sort of a press thing, wasn't it? Yeah. We went and did it.
威尔和克里斯·帕特一起去过太空营，对吧？我去过。我们去了阿拉巴马那个。真的吗？是的。那是某种媒体活动吧，对吧？是的。我们去了并完成了它。
And then we did it. We made it into a competition. It was me and Pratt against Liz Banks and Corden. Are you better at one? I did. Although the thing where they spun me around. Right round? Yeah.
然后我们完成了。我们把它变成了一场比赛。我和帕特对阵莉兹·班克斯和科登。你哪个比较擅长？我做到了。尽管他们把我转圈的那项。转呀转？是的。
Like a record baby. You know that one. No, that thing. We get it. Stop doing the thing with your hand. And the gyro thing. And I was all good. And then I got off that.
像一张唱片，宝贝。你知道那个。不，那个东西。我们懂。别再用手做那个动作了。还有那个陀螺仪的东西。我一切都好。然后我从那个上面下来。
And then for like 45 minutes. And then Pratt comes up to me and he goes, he goes, I was kind of like bent over. We were going to the next thing to try the G-Force. I'm like, I don't know if I can do this. And I was kind of bent over outside the building and Pratt comes up and he goes, you know, you're going to be okay.
然后大概有 45 分钟。接着帕特向我走过来，他说，他说，我当时有点像弯着腰。我们要去下一个项目尝试 G 力。我就像，我不知道我能不能行。我当时有点弯着腰在建筑物外面，帕特走过来对我说，你知道的，你会没事的。
But you know, sometimes they say that that, that feeling you're having can, can last for a couple of weeks. Oh my God. And I go, yeah, but I go, what? And he goes, yeah. And then I look at him and I go, you motherfucker. I want to do that though.
但是你知道，有时他们说，你感受到的那种感觉可以，可以持续几个星期。哦，天哪。我说，真的吗，我说，什么？他说，对。然后我看着他，我说道，你个王八蛋。不过我也想那样做。
I want to, but look at Jay, Jay and I went to the Dodger's game last week and the Cubs lost Dodgers one. But Jay took a video of me after I ate some food. Yeah. You remember that, Jay? No. I remember I had mustard all over my shirt. Oh yeah.
我想，但你看杰，上周我和杰伊去看了道奇队的比赛，小熊队输了，道奇队赢了。但杰在我吃了一些食物后拍了一段我的视频。是的。你还记得吗，杰？不。我记得我衬衫上全是芥末。哦，对了。
Are you trying to do like the opposite of weightlessness? What do you do? Yeah, he had, granddad got some mustard on his top. I didn't even know when I was walking around greeting all these people. You know, you weren't walking. You were just sitting heavy. You were sitting heavy in a chair
你是想做类似失重状态相反的事情吗？你是怎么做的？是的，他有，老爷子身上沾了点芥末。我到处跟这些人打招呼时甚至都不知道。你才不是在走路。你只是重重地坐着。你重重地坐在一把椅子上，
and your stomach shelf had a big dollop of mustard sitting on the top. And Jason turns this video on and he goes. On the summit of it. Yeah. He goes, oh, granddad's first game. And he just was videotaping my shirt. Oh, he wanted to know when halftime was.
你的肚子上有一大坨芥末。然后杰森打开这个视频说。在它的顶端。是的。他说，哦，老爷子的第一场比赛。他只是在拍我的衬衫。哦，他想知道中场休息是什么时候。
And I said, you know what, Sean? Let's just hang on for another hour and you'll be done. Oh, speaking of hanging on for another hour, ready for our guest? I sure am. Oh, I'm so excited. Are you sure you booked the right one? That's, that's great.
我说，你知道吗，肖恩？再坚持一个小时，你就搞定了。哦，说到再坚持一个小时，准备好迎接我们的嘉宾了吗？我当然准备好了。哦，我太兴奋了。你确定你预订对了吗？太棒了。
Well, this is so sad and so expected. He's a very, very funny human being. He's been making me laugh since he was a kid and I was still an adult. But fun fact, he's also an excellent ice skater. There may have been a little hockey movie. You got to exercise those skills in. Going from child star on Nickelodeon to Saturday Night Live
好吧，这真是太悲哀了，但也完全在意料之中。他是一个非常非常搞笑的人。他从还是个孩子的时候就一直在逗我笑，而我当时还是个成年人。但有趣的事实是，他也是一个优秀的滑冰运动员。有一部小曲棍球电影你得发挥那些技能。从尼克国际儿童频道的童星到《周六夜现场》
is a pretty solid trajectory for a young comedian. And he's since been nominated for four prime time and he's Keenan. As the longest tenured Saturday Night Live cast member ever. He just finished his 19th season. It's Keenan Thompson. It's Keenan. I knew it was Keenan.
对年轻喜剧演员来说是一条相当稳固的发展轨迹。他后来获得了四次黄金时段提名，他就是基南（Keenan）。作为《周六夜现场》史上任职时间最长的常驻演员。他刚刚完成了他的第 19 季。他是基南·汤普森（Kenan Thompson）。是基南。我知道是基南。
I knew it was Keenan. I knew it was Keenan. Very happy. You guys. What hockey movie? Mighty Ducks. Mighty Ducks. Mighty Ducks.
我知道是基南。我知道是基南。非常高兴。伙计们。什么曲棍球电影？《野鸭队员》。《野鸭队员》。《野鸭队员》。
Take that dirty braves hat off immediately. Oh, wow. I can't. I'm actually in Atlanta. So I really have to represent. I'm sorry. You're in Atlanta right now? Yeah.
马上把那顶恶心的勇士队帽子摘下来。哦，哇。我不能。我其实在亚特兰大。所以我真的必须代表一下。我很抱歉。你现在在亚特兰大？是的。
But you don't live there. Two and three. No, I don't live here. I'm from here. So. Huh. So there's that. Are you visiting or working?
但你不住在那里。二和三。不，我不住这。我是这儿的人。所以。哈。所以就是这样。你是来探亲还是工作的？
I'm just visiting. Brought the kids home to see grandma and granddad. Oh, that's nice. Now, so then does that make you a braves hand? It does. Or you just like the hat? I am a braves fan. Is that a problem?
我只是来探亲。带孩子们回家看爷爷奶奶。哦，那太好了。那么，这会让你成为勇士队的铁粉吗？是的，或者你只是喜欢这顶帽子？我是勇士队球迷。这有什么问题吗？
I feel like it's turning into an issue. Yeah, I'm sorry. We'll take care of you in the playoffs. Do you miss Freddie Freeman? Were you on board with that whole situation? We'll be right with you guys. Hold on. Yeah, just one sec.
我觉得这正在变成一个问题。是的，我很抱歉。我们在季后赛照顾你。你想念弗雷迪·弗里曼（Freddie Freeman）吗？你对整个情况满意吗？我们马上就来陪你们。稍等。对，就一秒钟。
I'll talk to Freeman and talk. I felt like he put in a good amount of time with us. And yeah, he helped us win last year. So you were done with him? Wasn't necessarily done, but he's free to move on if he wants a bigger check. What an answer. What an answer.
我和弗里曼谈谈。我觉得他在我们这里花了很多时间。而且，是的，他帮助我们赢得了去年的冠军。所以你对他就无所谓了？也不是无所谓，但如果他想要更大的支票，他可以自由离开。多么精彩的回答。多么精彩的回答。
He took less with us, I think. He took less. Well, I don't think he had a choice. You guys booed in him. No way. Yes way. Wow. Yes way.
我觉得他跟我们拿得少。他拿得少。嗯，我想他别无选择。你们嘘他了。怎么会。确实如此。哇。千真万确。
Didn't you see him crying last week? I thought that was because he's a family man or something. I didn't know. I didn't know the family was in his babies. Jason, can you hear it? I just heard our ratings drop. Oh God. Call them back.
你没看到他上周哭了吗？我以为那是因他是顾家男人什么的。我不知道。我不知道家里有他的小宝贝们。杰森，你能听到吗？我刚听到我们的收视率下降了。哦，天哪。把他们叫回来。
Damn. Baseball. I mean, there are a lot of people who love sports and then they're like, but baseball? Are you fucking kidding me? It's the best. Are you fucking kidding me? It's the best.
该死。棒球。我的意思是，有很多人热爱体育，然后他们会说，但是棒球？你在跟我开玩笑吧？这是最棒的。你在跟我开玩笑吧？这是最棒的。
That's what it is. There are things about that. I'm being a little. You know what though? Going to the games with Jason last week, I said to him, I go, I get it. I get it. It's America's favorite pastime.
事实就是这样。关于这个有一些。我有点。但你知道吗？上周和杰森去观看比赛时，我对他说，我懂了。我懂了。这是美国人最喜爱的消遣。
I understand it. It's really relaxing. If you look at it as a game instead of a sport, you can deal with the slow pace of it. Yeah. No, I like it. I do enjoy it. I've been with Jason before.
我理解了。这真的很放松。如果你把它当成一个游戏而不是一项运动，你就能应付它缓慢的节奏了。是的。不，我喜欢它。我确实很享受。我以前和杰森在一起过。
I stole a fly ball once when he was there with him. It's a foul ball. With his own glove. Foul ball with his glove. Going to a game, you can't not like it. You know, you just see those guys and then you see what they do and they're so professional and blah, blah, blah, blah.
他去的时候我曾抢过一个飞球。是个界外球。用他自己的手套。用他的手套接界外球。去看比赛，你不可能不喜欢它。你知道，你只要看到那些家伙，然后看到他们的所作所为，他们是那么的专业，巴拉巴拉巴拉。
Bullshit. But it is a lot of fun. It really is. It's so good to see you guys. How's it going with the granddad and grandma right now? It's going great. That's your mom and dad, your kids' grandparents. Yeah?
胡说八道。但这真的很有趣。确实如此。很高兴见到你们。爷爷奶奶现在怎么样？一切都很好。那是你的父母，你孩子的祖父母。是吗？
That's right. Okay. So the kids are with them so we can have it. No fights yet? They're coming. I can feel it. The little ones getting a little agitated. How long you been there?
没错。好吧。所以孩子们和他们在一起，这样我们才能有。还没吵架吧？快了。我能感觉到。小家伙有点急躁了。你们去那儿多久了？
Just since last night. Oh, it's already tense. Yeah. And you're living there at the house with them or in a hotel? We're Airbnb-ing. Oh, yeah. Actually, I caught this Airbnb kind of like around the corner
就从昨晚开始。哦，已经很紧张了。对。你们是和他们住在同一栋房子里还是住酒店？我们住 Airbnb。哦，是的。其实，我订的这个 Airbnb 就在我长大的教堂拐角处。
from the church I grew up in. So this is like super stomping grounds I get to share with them. It's nice. Oh, nice. How many kids you got, Kenan? Two girls. Two girls?
所以这就像是我可以和他们分享的超级地盘。挺好的。哦，真不错。基南，你有几个孩子？两个女孩。两个女孩？
Two girls, mm-hmm. Ages, sweet. Eight and four. Best guess on their ages, eight and four. Yeah, I'm gonna go ballpark, eight and four. Yeah, it's always safe. You know what I mean? Good couple of numbers.
两个女孩，嗯。年龄，真甜。八岁和四岁。对他们年龄的最佳猜测，八岁和四岁。是的，我估计在八岁和四岁左右。是的，这总归很安全。你知道我的意思吗？两个不错的数字。
Actually, the four-year-old is turning for the end of the month, so she's almost four. Yeah. But yeah. Okay, we'll allow it. It's so fun. Now, do you keep them busy during the summer with camp or doing these family jumps?
其实，老四月底就要满四岁了，所以她快四岁了。对。但是，好吧，我们允许。太有趣了。那么，暑假期间你会让他们忙于夏令营或进行这些家庭旅行吗？
Usually I've been working, but now that the show is no more, I have the summer off, so we've been kind of just traveling and catching up with family. You're talking about the Kenan Thompson show? I am. I'm talking about the actual sitcom of mine.
通常我一直在工作，但既然节目没有了，我夏天就放假了，所以我们基本上就是到处旅行，和家人叙叙旧。你是在说《基南·汤普森秀》吗？是的。我在说我自己的情景喜剧。
I saw that and I thought it was hysterical and fantastic. I thought you were great. How many seasons did you do on that and how did you do your schedule? Were you doing SNL all year and then doing your show during the summer? No, I mean, when we started, we did two seasons. When we started, we started,
我看了那个，我觉得它既滑稽又棒极了。你演得真好。你拍了多少季？你的日程是怎么安排的？你是一整年都在做 SNL，然后夏天拍你的节目吗？不，我的意思是，当我们开始的时候，我们拍了两季。当我们开始的时候，我们，
we were like the first show back from the pandemic, so they kind of squeezed it in in the fall, so we were kind of double duty in SNL in that show for... No way. Yeah, a couple months. You were doing it with Chris, right, Chris Redd? Exactly. How did that, sorry, how did that work then?
我们就像是疫情后第一档回归的节目，所以他们在秋天把档期挤进去了，所以我们有一段时间在 SNL 和那个节目里做双重任务……不会吧。是的，几个月。你是和克里斯一起做的，对吧，克里斯·雷德？没错。那进展得怎么样，抱歉，那当时是怎么运作的？
How did you double, you got to fly across the country? Yeah, we were kind of skipping out on the week and just showing up on Saturday, basically. And then on the hiatus weeks, we would just go back and work. So we didn't take a break for like nine weeks when we first started. And then the second season, we started in this...
你怎么能兼顾两边，你得飞越大半个国境？是的，我们基本上是跳过一周，星期六直接现身。然后在休息周，我们就回去工作。所以刚开始的时候，我们大概有九周没有休息。然后第二季，我们开始……
more so where it wasn't overlapping. I'm trying to think exactly. I think it was May, but... Can I ask a dumb question? The show's named after you. That would imply you had the juice to dictate where it would be shot. And why wasn't it shot in New York?
更倾向于不重叠。我想仔细想想。我想是五月，但是……我能问个愚蠢的问题吗？这个节目以你的名字命名。这暗示你有权决定在哪里拍摄。为什么它不在纽约拍摄？
Yeah. I'm a fan of L.A. I'm a big fan of L.A. And I felt like I spent a lot of time in New York and it's kind of hard to shoot shows in New York. Everything seems so complicated, especially like Miss Maisel shoots in the West Village all the time
对。我是洛杉矶的粉丝。我是洛杉矶的超级粉丝。我觉得我在纽约花了很多时间，而且在纽约拍节目有点难。一切看起来都那么复杂，特别是像《麦瑟尔夫人》一直在西村拍摄，他们把整个西村周围的停车位都占光了。似乎每个人都有点生气。我不想成为那种类型的节目。
and they just suck up the entire parking around the entire West Village. And it seems like everybody's kind of mad about it. And I didn't want to be that kind of show. I bet the other reason you shot in L.A. was because when you're shooting a multi-cam, you should be on the lot. The best people for multi-cams are in L.A.
我打赌你在洛杉矶拍摄的另一个原因是因为当你拍摄多机位时，你应该在片场。拍多机位最好的人才都在洛杉矶。我们都知道这一点。这看起来在后勤上是不可能的，既然你当时在做这个，为什么不直接在 30 号洛克菲勒中心拍，这不是很显而易见吗？
And we know this. It just seems this logistically impossible to do it since you were doing it like, why not shoot it at 30 Rock would kind of make a no-brainer sense, right? It would, but I guess I like to complicate things, man. I like to live on the fucking edge. And was Lauren producing it?
确实如此，但我想我喜欢把事情搞复杂，伙计。我喜欢在悬崖边缘生活。当时洛恩（Lorne）是制片人吗？
Lauren produced it. It was a brand new production. That's why I was doing no, because the reason is... I think we all wanted to travel. We needed vacation. We spent a lot of time in New York, especially in the fall and winter. But I honestly thought I was like,
洛恩是制片人。这是一个全新的制作。这就是为什么我在做……不，原因是因为……我想我们都想去旅行。我们需要度假。我们在纽约花了很多时间，尤其是在秋冬季节。但我真的以为，
oh, Keenan's going to bring the multi-cams back to NBC because it's been a while. And I saw that I was like, oh, that's going to be on the air for 12, 15 years. We thought, and we ended up doing a single cam, but we tried to make it look like a multi-fuel. It had a multi-fuel to it. And you had everybody, Don Johnson on there too.
哦，基南要把多机位节目带回 NBC，因为已经很久没有了。我看到时就想，哦，这要在电视上播 12、15 年了。我们当时以为，最后我们拍了单机位，但我们试图让它看起来像个多机位。它有一种多机位的赶脚。而且你把所有人都请来了，唐·约翰逊也在上面。
Killed it. Crushed it. Yeah, killed it. Constantly. He's such a good guy. And you make me laugh. Every time, you're one of those people every time I see you, you make me laugh, always.
演得绝了。太棒了。是的，太牛了。一直如此。他真是个好人。你总是让我发笑。每次，你都是那种每次我见到你都会让我笑的人，总是这样。
It's one of the things. Are you sure? Yeah, I did. It's one of the things. Am I doing it now? Yeah, absolutely. It's just you get that nice, warm smile on your face and I feel safe.
这是其中之一。你确定吗？是的，我确实笑了。这是其中之一。我现在笑了吗？对，绝对是。你脸上就是带着那种温暖的微笑，让我觉得很有安全感。
You guys, likewise, by the way. And we will be right back. And now back to the show. I read this, I got to find it, where did I put it? I read this off of your own website, which made me laugh out loud. This is your website. Bear with him, Kenan.
伙计们，彼此彼此，顺便说一句。我们马上回来。现在回到节目中。我读到这个，我得找找，我放哪儿了？我这是从你自己的网站上读到的，当时把我逗得哈哈大笑。这是你的网站。担待着点，基南。
This is the guy who spilled mustard on his shirt. It hasn't been updated since 07. Left to right, top to bottom, Sean. This is really funny. Keenan currently stars as a member of the Saturday Night Live crew of which he's been a member since 2003. He is currently the only black member of SNL.
这就是那个把芥末洒在衬衫上的人。它自 07 年以来就没更新过。从左到右，从上到下，肖恩。这真的太搞笑了。基南目前作为《周六夜现场》团队的成员主演，他自 2003 年起就一直是该节目的成员。他目前是 SNL 唯一的黑人成员。
What? I told you, it hasn't been updated since 2007, I think. Mike, he said, what? Oh my God. Isn't that great? Don't worry, I'm gonna get on my IT people. IEV. You should do some lo-fi sort of scratch out on only
什么？我告诉过你，我想它自 2007 年以来就没更新过。迈克，他说，什么？哦，天哪。这不是很棒吗。别担心，我要去找我的 IT 团队。IEV。你应该把“唯一”划掉，
and just change it to best. Oh, there you go. There you go. That's a solid thing. That's a champ right there. Congratulations, by the way. Who can make? Keenan's out the wazoo out there.
然后直接改成“最棒的”。哦，这样啊。原来如此。那倒是个稳妥的做法。这绝对是个狠人。顺便恭喜你。谁能做到？
Also, let me just praise you guys for a quick second. Jason, I'm so proud of you. Take your time, Keenan. Since the last time I saw you, Jason, you were hosting SNL and then you departed and became probably Netflix's greatest treasure. Oh, you're so nice, man. I'm so proud of you for that.
另外，请允许我简短地表扬你们一下。杰森，我为你感到骄傲。慢慢来，基南。自从上次见到你，杰森，你当时在主持 SNL，然后你离开了，成为了 Netflix 最伟大的宝藏。哦，你太好了，伙计。我为你感到骄傲。
You're very kind. I think y'all shooting Atlanta too. I know the streets. We did some time there, for sure. I love it. I'm so proud. Don't say you did some time. You have the best job in show business.
你太客气了。我想你们也在亚特兰大拍摄吧。我熟悉那里的街道。我们确实在那呆过一段时间，绝对的。我喜欢。我太骄傲了。别说你们在那呆过一段时间。你有演艺界最好的工作。
That place is a temple. It is a special place. I still would trade it all in to be a cast member. That is an absolute true story right there. Come back and host, it's way better. Yeah, well, the hosting gig is way better. I feel like you and I missed each other last time I was there. I remember talking to you on the phone
那个地方简直是圣殿。那是一个特殊的地方。我宁愿用这一切去换取成为常演嘉宾的机会。这绝对是一个真实的故事。回来主持吧，那样好得多。好吧，主持的工作确实好得多。我觉得上次我去那儿的时候，咱俩错过了。我记得在电话里跟你聊过，
because now that I'm back to you were in L.A. That's right, you just hosted and I wasn't there because we were shooting that damn show. That's right. But did you make it in to do that, to do SNL at all? And I just wasn't... I did it because we had a COVID shutdown. So I was quarantined for two weeks
因为现在我回到……你在洛杉矶。没错，你刚好去主持了，而我不在，因为我们在拍那部该死的剧。没错。但你有没有抽空去客串一下 SNL？而我只是没有……我去是因为我们因新冠疫情关停了。所以我被隔离了两周，
and I wasn't able to make it or else I would have. But that sounds nice. That sounds like you got some real good L.A. time there. Way to catch the virus. Yeah, I was walking up those runyon canyons and I saw Lawrence Fishburne twice. It was pretty awesome. Wait, what?
没能去，否则我会去的。听起来挺不错。听起来你在洛杉矶过得很开心。真会赶上病毒。对，我当时在爬鲁尼峡谷，我遇到了劳伦斯·菲什伯恩两次。挺棒的。等等，什么？
Randomly, he was exercising on the same hills, so... So wait, Keenan, I want to know because you do... I truly, truly mean it. Anytime I see you anywhere, you're one of those people where your face just shows up and you know it's going to be funny. Who in the world makes you laugh that hardest that you either work with or have worked with?
真巧，他在同一座山上锻炼，所以……所以等等，基南，我想知道，因为你……我真的、真的是发自内心地说。无论何时何地看到你，你都是那种只要你一露脸，大家就知道接下来一定会有趣的人。世界上有谁能让你笑得最开心，无论是你合作过的还是共事过的？
Well, I was getting back to you guys, I wasn't finished. Oh, God. I'm such a... I'm a big fan of the show. I'm so happy that you guys get to do something with your friends, you know what I mean? That like, is it lifting at all for either one of you? You know what I mean?
嗯，我正要回到你们的话题，我还没说完呢。哦，天哪。我真是个……我是这个节目的超级粉丝。我太高兴你们能和朋友们一起做点事情了，你知道我的意思吗？这甚至能给你们带来任何振奋吗，你们俩？你知道我的意思吗？
It's embarrassingly light. It's so light. It's so awesome. I'm so happy. We've crossed paths many, many times. You always brighten my day. I've never known, like I've never stopped and asked you questions that I wanted to ask you,
轻松得让人尴尬。太轻松了。太棒了。我太高兴了。我们曾多次擦肩而过。你总是让我的日子亮起来。我从没想过，就像我从未停下来问过那些我想问你的问题，
which is what this podcast is for, right? Oh my God. So I know, and they're going to be dumb questions, but I don't know the answers. So that's why I asked now that. I have you trapped in this. There's going to be a lot of them, Kenan. It's wrapped in fire.
这也是这个播客的意义所在，对吧？哦，天哪。所以我知道，这些会是愚蠢的问题，但我不知道答案。这就是为什么我现在要问，既然我把你困在这里了。会有很多问题的，基南。这是热情的围攻。
I want to know, was SNL a big deal to you growing up? Like, did you watch it? Because you're the first guest that was ever in the history of SNL cast. How do I get this right? I was the first cast member that was born after the start of the show, yes. After the show, yeah.
我想知道，对你成长过程中来说，SNL 是件大事吗？比如，你会看吗？因为你是 SNL 历史上第一位……我怎么说才对？我是第一个在节目开播后出生的演员，是的。节目开播后，对。
Oh, wow. Oh. Yeah, SNL was a huge deal. I mean, I think I caught on to it after my in living color run, but definitely like middle school, I was paying. It was like the Sandler, Chris Farley days. I was paying attention, like pretty strong.
哦，哇。哦。是的，SNL 是个大制作。我的意思是，我想我是在看了《生动色彩》（In Living Color）之后才开始关注它的，但到了初中时，我确实在关注。那是桑德勒、克里斯·法利（Chris Farley）的时代。我一直在关注，相当专注。
And then I went back and researched, you know, the Eddie Murphy days, because I remember my dad watching like Hot Tub and shit like that. I couldn't really watch at the time. So I had to go back and study Gumby and all that good stuff and, you know, Garrett's years and the original seven
然后我回去研究了，你知道的，艾迪·墨菲（Eddie Murphy）的时代，因为我记得我爸爸看《热浴盆》之类的破节目。我当时其实不能看。所以我不得不回去研究咕咕钟（Gumby）和所有那些好东西，你知道的，加里（Garrett）的岁月和最初的七人组，
and stuff like that. And, you know, since I've just been watching it for the rest of the duration. So from the Sandler years on, I've been a student and a huge fan, you know? And yeah, it was definitely a dream that I thought would never happen. And did you put yourself on a path to do it?
诸如此类。而且，你知道，从那以后我就一直在看。所以从桑德勒时代开始，我一直是一个学生和超级粉丝，你知道吗？是的，这绝对是一个我认为永远不会实现的梦想。那你自己有没有为之努力？
Like, did you want to take improv classes or stand up and stuff like that to sort of like get yourself ready for that? Was it something you had your eye on? I didn't do the traditionals. No, but unbeknownst to us, I mean, you know, it kind of was the best training I could ever have doing the Nickelodeon shows.
比如，你想过去上即兴表演课或单口喜剧之类的课程，好让自己为之做好准备吗？这是你一直盯着的目标吗？我没有走传统路线。不，但不知不觉中，我的意思是，你知道的，这可以说是我有生以来最好的训练，就是在尼克国际儿童频道做那些节目。
All that show was a sketch comedy show. Yeah, it was awesome. At such a young age. Keenan, I was, because you used to, I remember when you first started SNL, you didn't come in like some kid who was just like doing sketch in Chicago or whatever. You had a career and you had fans
所有那些节目都是小品喜剧。是的，太棒了。在那么年轻的时候。基南，我当时……因为你以前，我记得你刚开始演 SNL 的时候，你可不像某些刚从芝加哥做小品之类的小屁孩那样。你已经有了职业生涯，有了粉丝，
and you had been doing stuff. Like you had some juice and you knew what you were doing. A lot of cast members come on and they're nervous. It's probably, for a lot of them, it's their first time in front of a camera. Yeah. And you had grown up in front of a camera. Yeah, I was, I think I was lucky in that way.
而且你一直在做事。就像你有点实力，而且你知道自己在做什么。很多演员来的时候都很紧张。对他们中的许多人来说，这可能是他们第一次面对镜头。是的。而你是在镜头前长大的。是的，我想我在那方面很幸运。
Like I always, still to this day, I wished that I had gone to an improv experience or something like that, just to get better at flushing out what I think is funny and what everybody else might understand to be the same thing, just to connect those dots, you know what I mean? When you're writing a sketch or just, you know,
就像我一直以来，直到今天，我还是希望我曾经有过即兴表演的经历或类似的东西，只是为了更好地弄清楚我认为什么是搞笑，以及其他人可能也理解为同样的事情，只是为了把这些点连接起来，你知道我的意思吗？当你写一个小品或者只是，你知道的，
writing in general. But yeah, the Nickelodeon was great training. You just seemed to have such a great innate sense of where the audience is at in any particular sketch. And whether you kind of want to be in on the joke with them or be separate from them and kind of show them the joke. I mean, I don't know if any of that makes sense, but I don't know.
进行一般的写作时。但是，是的，尼克国际儿童频道的经历是很棒的训练。你似乎对观众在任何特定小品中的状态有一种非常好的内在感觉。无论是想和他们一起开玩笑，还是和他们保持距离，向他们展示这个笑话。我的意思是，我不知道这讲得通不通，但我不知道。
It does. You never push and you just always seem so relaxed. You put the audience in, in relaxation. Oh, I push. I shoves my ideas, especially if I think it's funny, but a lot of the time it's not, which is fine. It is. But I am in love with your impressions.
讲得通。你从不强求，而且你总是显得那么放松。你让观众感到放松。哦，我强求。我强推我的想法，特别是如果我觉得好笑的话，但很多时候并不好笑，这也没关系。确实如此。但我真的很迷恋你的模仿秀。
You do so many great impressions. Steve Harvey makes me pee in my pants. Bill Cosby makes me pee in my pants. Like the bartender, that character you did, Al Sharpton makes me pee in my pants. Oh man, thank you. I mean, I give it up to those guys because they're easier to do.
你模仿得太棒了。史蒂夫·哈维（Steve Harvey）让我笑得尿裤子。比尔·科斯比（Bill Cosby）让我笑得尿裤子。就像那个酒保，你演的那个角色，阿尔·夏普顿（Al Sharpton）让我笑得尿裤子。天哪，谢谢。我的意思是，我要向那些家伙致敬，因为他们更容易模仿。
They have tomes that I can like register in on, you know? Like Charles Barkley sounds like how he sounds. Steve Harvey sounds like how he sounds. You know, like Sharpton especially, like one of the greatest voices ever. So I guess I have good ears. Has Barkley ever reached out to you and been like, Oh yeah.
他们有我可以锁定音域的声调，你知道吗？就像查尔斯·巴克利（Charles Barkley）听起来就是他那个声音。史蒂夫·哈维听起来就是他那个声音。你知道的，尤其是夏普顿，拥有史上最棒的声音之一。所以我想我有好耳朵。巴克利有没有联系过你，然后说：哦，耶。
Hey man. I just saw him, like calm it down. No, Barkley loves it. Steve Harvey didn't love it in the beginning. He didn't? Did he send you a note? He didn't love it. No, I know him.
嘿，伙计。我刚看到他，冷静点。不，巴克利很喜欢。史蒂夫·哈维一开始并不喜欢。他不喜欢？他给你发过便条吗？他不喜欢。不，我认识他。
So he would definitely like send messages through mutual friends or just through the press and be like, hey, tell a little fat boy to knock it off. And be like, all right, take it easy. Wow. And then did you lean into it a little bit more? I'd never stopped. As soon as he does something that is, you know,
所以他绝对会通过共同的朋友或通过媒体发消息说，嘿，告诉那个小胖子消停点。然后就像，好吧，放轻松。哇。然后你稍微更倾向于模仿他了吗？我从未停止。只要他做出……你知道的，
something to reflect, like whenever he steps out of family feud and does something else, I'm on that too. You know what I mean? It's just, if you're on the radar, you're on the radar. That's right. I guess if people are, if they're big stars and they know what the game is
有什么值得反映的事，每当他离开《家庭问答》（Family Feud）去做别的事情时，我也在关注。你知道我的意思吗？就是这样，如果你在雷达上，你就在雷达上。没错。我想如果人们是，如果他们是大明星，而且他们知道游戏的规则，
and they're at the top of the game, that they're kind of, when it comes to sort of making fun of them a little bit, they're open. It's open season, right? It should be, you know? I mean, that's what I mean about being on the radar, you know, like you can capitalize off of life and then not have someone comment on that,
并且他们处于游戏的顶峰，那么当涉及到稍微取笑他们时，他们是开放的。这是公开的赛季，对吧？本该如此，你知道吗？我的意思是，这就是我所说的在雷达上的意思，你知道，就像你可以利用生活，然后不让别人对此发表评论，
you know what I mean? Yeah, of course. And also, I mean, any sort of drawn caricature or acted impersonation sort of by definition is an exaggeration of whatever it is that you do. And so, baked into that, you should know like, they're exaggerating to make a point, that they're trying to get to the comedy
你知道我的意思吗？是的，当然。而且，任何类型的夸张漫画或表演模仿，按定义来说，都是对你所做事情的某种夸张。所以，内置于其中的是，你应该知道，他们为了表达一个观点而进行夸张，他们试图通过做一些超出你常规的事情来达到喜剧效果。
by doing something more than what you do. So, people should temper their feelings about all of that. I definitely agree. I mean, I have to exaggerate because I'm not Steve Harvey. You know what I mean? So, right up there, really try to convince people that I, I don't know, Keenan, you're just a hat away. One hat, 50 buttons away from being Steve right now.
所以，人们应该对所有这些保持冷静的心态。我绝对同意。我的意思是，我必须夸张，因为我不是史蒂夫·哈维。你知道我的意思吗？所以，就在那里，真的努力去说服人们，我……我不知道，基南，你只需要一顶帽子。只要一顶帽子，50 个扣子，你现在就是史蒂夫了。
But I feel like the audience would look at me like I'm insane if I was really trying to be like, no, no, no, take me seriously as a person. I do wonder where those five button jackets had gone. They're long. Everybody loves a mid-thigh, longer outer jacket. Belt it and cinch it. Belt it.
但我感觉，如果我真的去说“不、不、不，请把我当成一个正经人来看待”，观众会觉得我疯了。我确实很好奇那几款五粒扣夹克都去哪儿了。它们太长了。每个人都喜欢大腿中部长度、偏长的外衣。系上腰带，束紧。系上腰带。
Do you know, you know, Keenan, when you meet those people also, I don't even just mean like out on, if you do it publicly on the show on SNL, but, and you guys too, you know that if you take yourself too seriously, and I don't care if you're up or if you're, or if you're below, I don't care where you're at,
你知道吗，基南，当你遇到那些人时——不仅是我指的在外面，如果你在节目中公开这么做，比如在SNL上，还有你们也是——你知道的，如果你把自己看得太重，我不在乎你是红了还是过气了，我不在乎你处在什么位置，
you gotta be able to laugh at yourself and allow people. And you can kind of tell who, what somebody is, by whether or not they can take a fucking joke about themselves. Yeah, yeah, for sure. The boy we live with, a lot of people who don't wanna laugh at themselves. The one thing that made me nervous though,
你必须能够嘲笑自己，并允许别人这样做。你其实能通过一个人是否能拿自己开个该死的玩笑，来看出他究竟是个什么样的人。对，对，确实如此。我们身边有很多不愿意嘲笑自己的人。不过，让我感到紧张的一件事是，
that way back in the day, and we spoke to David about this, when David Spade was on the show, when he used to do Hollywood Minute, that those were sort of like crushing days. Did you remember that Keenan, when Spade used to do that back in the day, like in the 90s, he did that Hollywood minute?
很久以前——我们和大卫谈过这个——当大卫·斯佩德在节目中时，当他以前做“好莱坞速递”（Hollywood Minute）的时候，那些日子简直可以说是让人崩溃的。基南，你还记得吗，斯佩德以前在90年代做那个“好莱坞速递”的时候？
Epic, to the point where Eddie Murphy called, and was like, yo, what's up? You know what I'm saying, like, y'all dissing me? Dude, I'll kick your ass. Yeah, it was a nasty call. But you need that human peak in the window of a person to wanna still be a fan of them, I think. You know what I mean?
太绝了，甚至到了埃迪·墨菲打电话来质问：“哟，怎么回事？你知道我在说什么吗，你们是在贬低我吗？老兄，我要踢你的屁股。”是的，那是一个充满敌意的电话。但我认为，要想继续成为某人的粉丝，你还是需要看到一个人身上那种展现人性弱点的时刻。你知道我的意思吗？
Like I don't wanna see somebody, like just stay in the, I'm a tough guy role, you know what I mean? Like the best tough guys, like the real ones, are usually big, giant teddy bears, you know what I mean? Yeah. I remember going to do a hockey,
就像我不想看到有人一直保持着“我是个硬汉”的角色，你知道我的意思吗？就像最棒的硬汉，那些真正的硬汉，通常都是巨大无比的泰迪熊，你知道我的意思吗？是的。我记得有一次我去参加一个冰球，
I know that you like hockey, we brought it before, and when I did the hockey awards once, and I did this, it was a real sweaty bit, I'll admit that. And I was trying, wait, you've hosted the hockey awards before too, I think. And H.L. Awards twice.
我知道你喜欢冰球，我们之前也提过，有一次我去主持冰球颁奖典礼，我做了这个——这是一个让人直冒冷汗的环节，我承认这一点。当时我试图……等等，我想你也曾主持过冰球颁奖典礼。而且是两次NHL颁奖典礼。
H.L. Awards, yeah. That's right, I just did it. So I did it a few years back, and I remember doing this bit where I was like, I was like, I'm gonna go into the crowd, and I'm gonna kind of do some bits based on these, and just fuck with them. Always works.
NHL颁奖典礼，对。没错，我刚做过。所以我几年前做过，我记得当时我搞了个环节，我说我要走进观众席，根据这些人的情况做一些互动，顺便整蛊他们一下。这招百试百灵。
And guess, yeah, always works, always works. With athletes, especially hockey players, they took themselves so fucking seriously. And to the point that I had, but what was great was the biggest stars, Sidney Crosby, was the one who took it the best, and had a laugh at it about it, and I was like, what a fucking stud.
猜怎么着，对，百试百灵，百试百灵。面对运动员，尤其是冰球运动员时，他们把自己看得太该死的重要了。以至于我不得不——但棒就棒在，最大的明星——西德尼·克罗斯贝——是最能开得起玩笑、对此付之一笑的人，当时我就想：真是个该死的硬汉。
He's the biggest, he's on the top of the mountain, and he just won it at all. And even Patrick Kana did the same thing, he plays for Chicago, and then I did a thing back in Atlanta for TNT Broadcast, and I made a joke with him on the broadcast, this fall, or this spring,
他是最大牌的，站在金字塔尖，而且赢得了一切。帕特里克·凯恩也做了同样的事情，他为芝加哥效力，后来我在亚特兰大为TNT转播做过一个节目，今年秋天（或者今年春天）我在节目中拿他开了个玩笑，
and then I called him after I got a text, and I said, hey, Pat, you know, I was just goofing around, and he goes, oh yeah, man, I'm totally good. I totally got it. I loved it. And I was like, what a stud. Huge star, what a stud.
然后我给他打了电话，我收到了他的短信，我说：“嘿，帕特，你知道的，我只是在瞎胡闹。”他说：“噢，没关系，兄弟。我完全理解。我很喜欢。”当时我就想：真是个硬汉。超级巨星，真是个硬汉。
I mean, the rest of them are just worried about punching each other, I think. You know, they punch each other for a living, so since they're always kind of somber. I didn't want them to punch me for a living, because it would end my living. Right. Keenan, I want to ask you,
我的意思是，其他人大概只想着互相打架吧。你知道的，他们靠互相挥拳谋生，所以他们总是显得有点郁闷。我可不想让他们靠打拳谋生，因为那会结束我的生计。对。基南，我想问你，
being the longest cast member at Center Night Live, do you- Longest tenured. Longest tenured, yeah, sorry, bro. Just a family hot cast, bro. Jesus, dude. And I'm sorry if you get asked this question a lot, but do you still get thrilled?
作为周六夜现场（Saturday Night Live）资历最深的演员，你——资历最深。资历最深，对，抱歉，兄弟。只是一个……家庭热播卡司，兄弟。天哪，老兄。如果这个问题你已经被问过很多次了，我很抱歉，但你现在还会感到激动吗？
Do you still get excited? Where are you, as far as energy, excitement? Because, I mean, for us, I hope you never leave. I mean, you are like- Yeah, Keenan, I think that you've got one of the best, you're one of the people, I say this to people all the time, there are very few people who have the kind of timing
你还会感到兴奋吗？就精力和兴奋感而言，你目前处于什么状态？因为，对我们来说，我希望你永远不要离开。我的意思是，你就像是——是的，基南，我认为你拥有最好的——你是那种——我总是对别人说，很少有人能拥有像你这样的节奏感，
that you do, you have unreal timing. Thank you. Thank you very much. Jesus, that took a second. Oh, yeah, it was both like that up later. I'm out of practice, it's summertime, yeah, yeah, yeah. Yeah, when do you just, do you get nervous at all? Nervous and excited for every show, even dress rehearsal.
你的节奏感简直绝了。谢谢。非常感谢。天哪，这花了一会儿才反应过来。哦，对，后来都那样了。我生疏了，现在是夏天，对，对，对。是的，你什么时候会——你一点也不紧张吗？每场演出都很紧张且兴奋，甚至是彩排。
You know, almost more excited for dress rehearsal, because it doesn't count, and we can kind of just go as crazy as possible, so. I love that. I try to turn that nerves into, I don't give a Fs, you know what I mean, and then just kind of go crazy or whatever, and then tone it down for the live show or whatever,
你知道的，对彩排甚至更兴奋，因为彩排不算正式播出，我们可以尽可能地疯狂发挥，所以。我喜欢这样。我试着把这种紧张转化为“我不在乎”的心态，你知道我的意思吗？然后就开启疯狂模式之类的，接着再为直播节目稍微收敛一点，或者诸如此类的，
but depending on what the audience is doing, yeah. We'll be right back. All right, back to the show. Keenan Thompson, I wanna ask you, you have, you've expanded your kind of life into being a producer and quite prolific. You have a lot going on at your company. And. Trying, yes.
不过这也取决于观众的反应，对。我们马上回来。好的，回到节目中。基南·汤普森，我想问你，你已经把你的生活拓展到了制片人领域，而且相当多产。你的公司有很多业务在推进。而且。在尝试，是的。
Tell me a couple of things, why you wanted to start it, and, because I think this is fascinating, and I love it, and I'm on board. I'm an ensemble guy, you know? I grew up doing theater, and I, you know, every cast I've been in has been, you know, filled with amazing people. I'm not a stand up, and I'm thankful for that,
跟我说说有哪几项，为什么你想创办它，因为我觉得这太迷人了，我很喜欢，我完全支持。我是一个团队型的人，你知道吗？我从小演戏剧长大，而且我，你知道我待过的每一个剧组，你知道的，都充满了了不起的人。我不是个脱口秀演员，我很庆幸这一点，
because I feel like, you know, the stand up pursuit is such an individual pursuit. You kind of get robbed of the joy of working with people, the ability to work with other people, like all kinds of things. Like I see a lot of stand up struggle when they come to SNL because it is such an ensemble environment. But as far as producing goes,
因为我觉得，你知道，追求单口喜剧是一件非常个人的事情。你会因此被剥夺与人合作的快乐，与其他人共事的能力，以及各种各样的体验。比如我看到很多单口喜剧演员来到SNL时会感到挣扎，因为这里完全是一个集体环境。但就制片而言，
I'm just a big fan of, you know, knowing the struggles of, you know, us working actors and the audition hustle and this and the other, whatever I can do to help, you know, smooth that out or offer more opportunity or anything. I'm kind of all about it. So I'm beyond proud of our company, Artist for Artist. I've had other production companies with, you know,
我只是非常热衷于——了解我们这些职业演员的挣扎，试镜时的奔波，诸如此类的事情——无论我能做些什么来让这些过程变得更顺畅一点，或者提供更多的机会，或者别的什么。我对此可以说是全力支持。所以我对我们的公司“艺术家为艺术家”（Artists for Artist）感到无比自豪。我以前和其他公司合作过，你知道的，
friends from Nickelodeon in the days that are still going and a podcast company and like, you know, all kinds of stuff, you know, to kind of just offer opportunities, umbrella opportunities for whoever wants to be creative. I love that. And tell me about Mike Tyson, because I have a story about Mike Tyson.
当年尼克国际儿童频道的朋友们，公司现在还在运营，还有一个播客公司，以及各种各样的东西，你知道的，就是为了给任何想要搞创作的人提供机会，提供一个全方位的机会平台。我太喜欢这个了。跟我聊聊迈克·泰森吧，因为我有一个关于迈克·泰森的故事。
Mike's the greatest. I mean, he's the champ, you know? He's a tortured soul, unfortunately, but, you know, he's a big, giant sweetheart. Aren't you working with him on something? Yeah, like, you know, he's one of our, you know, partners. So we're kind of, that's our thing. We want to be like a 360 incubator
迈克是最棒的。我的意思是，他是拳王，你知道吗？不幸的是，他是一个饱受折磨的灵魂，但是，你知道，他是一个巨大无比的大甜心。你不是正在和他合作什么项目吗？对，就像，你知道的，他是我们的合作伙伴之一。所以我们基本上，这就是我们的主旨。我们想成为一个360度的孵化器，
for artists and creatives. So we, you know, are pretty wrapped around Tyson, pretty tight, like my partner, you know, produced his last fight and, you know, he's doing his podcast hotboxing and, you know, the weed line, Tyson 2.0 and all that stuff is like, all up underneath the umbrella. So those are the kinds of things we want to do
面向艺术家和创意人士。所以我们，你知道的，和泰森绑定得相当紧密，比如我的合伙人，你知道的，制作了他的上一场比赛，而且，你知道的，他在做他的播客节目《Hotboxin'》，还有大麻品牌泰森2.0（Tyson 2.0）以及所有这些东西，基本上都在这个公司伞下。所以这些就是我们想要和大家一起做的事情。
with everybody. Wait, sorry, Jason, wanted to get a pen for the weed. Yeah, can we just double back to the weed company? Yeah, yeah, yeah. How's that going for him? And how do you hear that the product is good? The product is great. They just came out with probably
等等，抱歉，杰森，想拿支笔来记大麻的事。是的，我们能切回大麻公司那个话题吗？对，对，对。他那个业务现在怎么样？你怎么听说产品很好的？产品非常棒。他们最近刚刚推出了可能是
one of the greatest zeitgeist edibles ever, which is the Tyson bites, where they're selling ears that have a bite missing inside them. That's come on. It's pretty incredible. And that was my partner's idea. So like, I love that guy. You know, we're friends.
有史以来最契合时代精神的软糖零食之一，也就是“泰森之咬”（Tyson Bites），他们售卖的是少了一块耳朵形状的软糖。得了吧，这太绝了。这简直不可思议。而且那是我的合伙人的主意。所以，我太喜欢这家伙了。你知道的，我们是朋友。
And how does Mike feel about that when that's pitched to him as an idea? He was like, oh my God, that's amazing that we should probably get Holy feeling about it. By the way, you know what? You know what? So again, example of a guy who's like able to laugh at himself at this thing.
当这个主意被当作创意向迈克提出时，他有什么反应？他当时说：“哦，天哪，这太棒了，我们大概应该弄点——”他对此感觉如何？顺便问一句，你知道吗？你知道吗？所以再次证明，这是一个能够拿自己开玩笑的人。
Oh, forget about it. Mike is a big giant sweetheart. I mean, he's ferocious, you know, so you don't want to get on the wrong side of things, which... Wait. You know what? Sorry, Sean, the ferociousness, you said it, the way that he used to hit people.
哦，别提了。迈克是个巨大无比的大甜心。我的意思是，他是极其凶猛的，你知道的，所以你可不想惹毛他，因为……等等。你知道吗？抱歉，肖恩，那种凶猛，你刚才提到了，他以前击打别人的方式。
Crazy. I don't think anyone, even an MMA or whatever, no one has been that violent inside. That guy just... I mean, God bless Custom Model for seeing that foreseen talent that nobody else could see. He was just like, you could decimate the world. He was telling Mike that.
疯狂。我不认为任何人，甚至在综合格斗（MMA）或别的什么领域，没有人曾像他那样具有内在的破坏力。这家伙简直——我的意思是，上帝保佑卡斯·达马托（Cus D'Amato），他看到了那种别人根本看不到的潜能。他当时就对迈克说：“你能把整个世界打得粉碎。”
And Mike was like, looking at him like, this guy's crazy. Like, how could he lose to anybody still to this day? You say he just had a fight? Yeah, he just... Yeah, he had a fight in the pandemic. I heard somebody. Yeah. And it was him and Roy Jones.
迈克当时看着他，心想：这家伙疯了吧。像他这样的人怎么可能会输给任何人，直到今天依然如此？你说他刚打了一场比赛？对，他刚——对，他在疫情期间打了一场比赛。我听说有人。对。是他和罗伊·琼斯。
Right. I watched that fight. Yeah, it was a good one. How'd that go? It was interesting. Like two old dudes fighting in the backyard, a little bit. But it was definitely interesting because, you know,
没错。我看过那场比赛。对，那是一场精彩的比赛。结果怎么样？挺有意思的。有点像两个老头在后院打架。但它绝对很有趣，因为，你知道的，
when the fight was done, Tyson was kind of just coming alive, you know what I mean? So I was kind of worried for Roy because if he came out like that, you know, he might have put a hurting on that guy. Yeah. So how did it end? It was a draw, I think.
当比赛结束时，泰森刚刚开始进入状态，你知道我的意思吗？所以我有点为罗伊担心，因为如果泰森当时是以那种状态出拳的话，你知道的，他可能会把那家伙打得很惨。是的。那结果是怎么样的？我想是个平局。
They set like it's just gonna be like a couple of rounds or something like that and it was over? It was like six to eight rounds, something like that. And I think it was... I don't think it was more than six, right? Because they were tired. Something like that. Yeah, yeah, they were pretty tired afterwards.
他们不是说这就打几个回合之类的，然后就结束了吗？大概是六到八个回合，类似这样的。而且我觉得是——我觉得不超过六个回合吧？因为他们累了。差不多吧。对，对，他们打完之后累得够呛。
But yeah, Tyson was starting to come alive. It was crazy. You met him, Sean? I have a survival story from Mike Tyson. Oh, what happened? So I was in New York City. This is like 1999. And I was at Harry Winston Jewelry.
不过，是的，泰森当时开始进入状态了。太疯狂了。你见过他吗，肖恩？我有一个从迈克·泰森手下生还的故事。哦，发生什么了？当时我在纽约市。大概是1999年吧。我在哈利·温斯顿珠宝店（Harry Winston Jewelry）。
Just working there for the summer or? Or what? Because I had to. Because I had to. I like this way, can I help you? Would you like a pin? Hot outside, isn't it? Can I just show you?
只是在那里打暑期工吗？还是别的什么？因为我得工作。因为我必须这么做。我喜欢这种方式，请问有什么我可以帮您的？您想要一支笔吗？外面很热，对吧？我能给您展示一下吗？
I know you're not here for a tennis bracelet, but let me just show you this. So I had a friend of mine with me, this girl, who was going to be my date at some function thing. So they said, you know what? Take her to Harry Winston, borrow some jewelry that you have to return the next day. Great, so we walk in and I see this gigantic,
我知道您不是来买网球手链的，但请允许我给您展示一下这个。当时我有个女性朋友陪着我，她要在某个社交活动上当我的女伴。所以他们对我说：“你知道吗？带她去哈利·温斯顿，借一些珠宝，第二天得还回来。”太好了，于是我们走进去，我看到一个身形巨大、
massive guy with his shirt off in the back hallway with huge diamonds around his neck. Like, must have been a million bucks worth of diamonds. And I was like, in my head, I'm 29 years old. And in the head, I'm like, who's this douchebag? Like, what? Why are you standing in Harry Winston with your shirt off? Like, who does he think he is?
极其魁梧的家伙，光着膀子站在后走廊里，脖子上戴着巨大的钻石。那脖子上的钻石至少价值一百万美元。我当时心里想，我当时29岁嘛，我心想：这混蛋是谁啊？什么情况？你为什么光着膀子站在哈利·温斯顿？他以为他是谁啊？
So I took my shirt off. No. I had no idea who he was. Oh my God. Took my shirt off and he was leaning in on the door jam right up this room. And I was in the next room, right in the door jam next to, I go, give me some jewelry.
于是我也把衬衫脱了。没有啦。我根本不知道他是谁。哦，天哪。我把衬衫脱了，当时他正靠在这个房间的门框上。我就在隔壁房间，紧挨着那个门框，我说：“给我拿点珠宝。”
And the girl gave me some jewelry. And I mimicked him right next to him. Where is that picture? And I took a picture, but it was before cell phones. And I can't fucking find it. And my friend, Ashley, she goes, fucking put your shirt on right now. Do you know who that is?
那个女孩就拿了一些珠宝给我。我就站在他旁边模仿他的动作。那张照片在哪儿？我拍了照片，但那是手机还没普及的年代。而且我死活找不到了。我的朋友阿什利（Ashley）对我说：“快把你的衬衫穿上，立刻！你知道那是谁吗？”
I'm like, what? She goes, that's fucking Mike Tyson. What are you, crazy? He's going to beat the shit out of you. And he laughed. And he laughed. And I was like, oh, I didn't know that was Mike Tyson. And we took a photo.
我说：“什么？”她说：“那是该死的迈克·泰森！你疯了吗？他会把你揍得屁滚尿流的。”然后他笑了。然后他也笑了。当时我就想：噢，我不知道那是迈克·泰森。然后我们拍了张照片。
Oh my God. That's my story. He's a big giant. We were both shirtless. That's what I'm saying. Like, the most ferocious guys are usually, you know, teddy bears at heart. You know, they still have, you know, heart and emotion.
哦，天哪。这就是我的故事。我们俩都赤着上身。这就是我想说的。就像，最凶猛的家伙通常内心里都是泰迪熊。你知道的，他们仍然有心肝，有情感。
And, you know, he's one of those people. Did he explain why he had his top off at? I think he was just being like, if you're in that kind of shape, you would walk around with no shirt on probably too. I'm not going to walk around with a, I'm not going to walk around with my shirt off, but I will wear a life partner beater. Uh-huh.
而且，你知道的，他就是那种人。他有没有解释他当时为什么光着膀子？我想他大概只是觉得——如果你练成他那种身材，你大概也会光着膀子到处走吧。我才不会光着膀子到处走呢，不过我倒是会穿一件背心。呃-huh。
Like a life partner beater. Yeah. I'll wear a life partner beater. I'm sure everybody, what it really looks like, regardless of that. A life partner beater. Yeah. Kenan.
就像一件老头衫一样。对。我会穿一件老头衫。我确信每个人，不管实际上看起来怎么样。一件老头衫。对。基南。
Stains or no stains? What? I don't care. Kenan, when's the last time a musical guest on SNL had you nervous? Ooh. Nervous? You know, just like, oh my God,
有污渍还是没污渍？什么？我不在乎。基南，上一次SNL的音乐嘉宾是谁让你感到紧张的？哦。紧张？你知道的，就是那种“天哪，
I'm going there for rehearsal. Oh yeah. I'm going to stand out there when they perform. Yeah. There's been several of those. Last one. Most recently, I mean, Kendrick was like that, but that was so long.
我要去彩排了”。哦，对。当他们表演时，我要站在那里。对。有好几次这种情况。最近的一次。最近的话，我的意思是，肯德里克（Kendrick）就是那样，但那是好久以前了。
That counts. Kendrick tomorrow was like, that was like, oh my God, that came out. But they all blended together. I know that because you've been there a long time and there's so many shows. I don't mean that they're not. I mean, I was also excited for Lizzo.
那也算。明天的肯德里克就像是——哦天哪，那首歌出来了。但它们都混在一起了。我知道是因为你在那里呆了很久，有那么多期节目。我不是说它们不是。我的意思是，我也为莉佐（Lizzo）感到兴奋。
Like, I'm a big fan of her music, you know? And I'm a fan of her journey because she's cool. She's been in the game a long time, you know what I'm saying? And she's been on that one song that blew up. She said she wrote that shit like six years before it even came out or something and nobody wanted to give it the time of day. And it's just weird about the timing of the universe
比如，我是她音乐的超级粉丝，你知道吗？而且我是她一路走来的粉丝，因为她很酷。她在这一行混了很久了，你知道我的意思吗？而且她有过那首爆火的歌。她说她写那首破歌甚至是在它发行前的大约六年前，当时根本没有人想搭理她。这真是宇宙时间的奇妙之处，
because it just blew up and everybody was just like, of course, that's a hit song or whatever. But six years prior, nobody wanted to return her phone calls, you know? So it was nice to watch her have a moment and she destroyed the show. It was great. Yeah, she's very cool.
因为它突然爆火了，每个人都觉得：废话，那当然是一首热门歌曲之类的。但在六年前，根本没人愿意回她的电话，你知道吗？所以看到她迎来属于自己的高光时刻真的很棒，而且她把节目炸翻了。太棒了。对，她非常酷。
I like that. Jack White is another one. I'm huge. Jack White fan, he kills every single time. He's just a straight up rock star. Yeah, big time. Forget about like the Beyonce's and the Solanges and the Jay Z's and then, you know,
我喜欢这个。杰克·怀特（Jack White）是另一个。我是个超级大粉丝。杰克·怀特的粉丝，他每一次表演都全场炸裂。他简直就是个根正苗红的摇滚巨星。是的，非常大牌。别提碧昂丝（Beyonce）、索兰吉（Solange）、JAY-Z，还有，你知道的，
the Paul McCartney's like, those are obvious, you know? The J-Lo's, you know what I'm saying? Even Kanye, Kanye's done brilliant performances. Yeah, really different. Nobody makes everybody nervous more than Kanye. All right. Wait, now, Kenan, what, you know, cause I love the live theater
保罗·麦卡特尼（Paul McCartney）这些人了，那些都是显而易见的，你知道的？詹妮弗·洛佩兹（J-Lo），你知道我的意思吗？甚至坎耶（Kanye），坎耶做过极其惊艳的表演。是的，真的很不一样。没有人比坎耶更能让所有人感到紧张了。好吧。等等，现在，基南，什么——因为我喜欢现场戏剧，
and I love when anything can go wrong. What's one sketch that you did where you're like something major happened and you're like, oh, this is not going how I planned? Well, that happens, but it usually doesn't make the show. Whenever it's derailing like that, it's like, all right, we'll just cut this because this is amazing.
而且我喜欢任何可能出错的时刻。你演过哪个小品，让你觉得发生了什么重大状况，当时你心里想：“哦，这完全不是按我计划的在走”？嗯，这种情况确实会发生，但通常不会被剪进节目里。每当出现这种偏离轨道的情况时，通常就会变成：“好吧，我们直接把这段剪掉吧，因为这太惊人了。”
We'll try to get next week. There's always another show. But the best, I think live thing that we've had in recent years was 80s dresser got caught on camera changing her jacket and she could not get it back because she was slapping so hard because- Oh, 80 Bryant.
“我们下周再试一次。”总会有下一期的节目。不过我认为近年来我们经历过的最棒的直播事故，是艾迪·布赖恩特（Aidy Bryant）的服装助理在换装时被摄像头拍个正着，而且她怎么也脱不下来，因为她笑得太厉害了，因为——哦，艾迪·布赖恩特。
Yes. They had been rehearsing, you know, that little quick change moment and they thought they had it down. But for some reason, like when it's live and like the communication, you can't hear each other or whatever, it's just loud in there because the audience is enjoying it.
是的。他们之前排练过那个快速换装的环节，他们以为自己已经练熟了。但不知为什么，当它是直播时，由于沟通原因，你们互相听不见对方在说什么，或者诸如此类的，后台里面声音太大了，因为观众正看得津津乐道。
And I don't know, she missed it and she got hung out there on camera for a while and then had to like run away. And 80 was in tears and had all the rest of the talk to do. Oh my God, tears laughing or tears laughing? Oh, good. And because her dresser is one of the biggest sweethearts working there, you know?
而且我不知道，她错过了时机，然后在镜头前被晾在那儿好一会儿，接着不得不像逃跑一样跑开。艾迪当时眼泪都快笑出来了，而且还要完成剩下的台词。哦，天哪，是笑出了眼泪还是急哭了？哦，太好了。而且因为她的服装助理是在那里工作最好的人之一，你知道吗？
And like everybody, they're all so humble and, you know, they just wanna do their job and they can't imagine, you know, doing anything that would, you know, be a problem for the show or anything like that, you know what I mean? Like everybody's very like, the show is so important. They're amazing. It's so incredible how that crew is.
就像每个人一样，他们都非常谦逊，你知道的，他们只想做好自己的工作，根本无法想象自己会做出任何会对节目造成麻烦的事情，你知道我的意思吗？就像每个人都觉得这个节目太重要了。他们太了不起了。那个剧组简直不可思议。
Yeah. So when she got caught, she was just like beat red, you know what I mean? Like almost devastated, but the fact that we were all laughing and having fun with her and not knowing what's mad at her, it's just the beauty of live television. That was a great moment. So I would suggest watching that.
所以当她被抓包时，她简直是面红耳赤，你知道我的意思吗？几乎快崩溃了，但事实上我们所有人都在笑，都在和她一起乐呵，没有人对她生气，这就是直播电视的魅力所在。那真是一个美妙的时刻。所以我建议大家去看看那一幕。
What's the sketch that you do with Sudeikis all the time that I'm, that's, I'm... What's up with that? Oh my God. The best. The funniest. The best, I'm so glad we got to do it when he came back and hosted it.
你经常和苏戴奇斯（Sudeikis）一起演的那个小品叫什么名字，我一直在——这是什么情况？哦，天哪。最棒的。最好笑的。最棒的，我很高兴当他回来主持时我们能再次表演这个。
It was, it was fantastic. Oh my God, it's so good. My favorite joke in there is Bill Hader's being Lindsay Buckingham and never gets to talk, but the absolute best. But isn't there like a music cue that happens right away? And then you guys all do that dance and what? Yeah, it comes in usually with like a symbol,
简直太棒了。哦，天哪，太精彩了。我在里面最喜欢的笑话是比尔·哈德（Bill Hader）扮演林赛·白金汉（Lindsey Buckingham），结果永远没机会说话，绝对是绝无仅有的。但里面是不是有一个音乐Cue点马上就响起来？然后你们所有人开始跳那个舞，什么？对，通常伴随着一个镲片的声音切进来，
like a t-t-t-t-t-t-t-t. And guests are like, what's that? It's like, I don't know. I love that. Like the piano comes in the bass line or whatever. And then it just goes back into it. It's, it's so much fun. I love that.
就像 t-t-t-t-t-t-t-t。然后嘉宾会问：“那是什么？”就像是：“我不知道。”我太喜欢这个了。就像钢琴切进来，还有贝斯线之类的。然后音乐又回到了那个节奏。这真的——太有趣了。我太喜欢了。
It's gotta be fun when, when ex-cast members come back and either host or they, or they do a guest spot or... Free week. It's a free week for us. Right. You don't have to work too hard. Is there anybody that you just really is on your bucket list of people that you'd love to host or just hang out with
当以前的演员回来当主持，或者客串演出，或者——这一定很有趣。这是我们的闲暇周。对我们来说是轻松的一周。没错。你不用太卖力工作。有没有谁真的是你梦寐以求想要邀请来主持，或者一起消磨时间，
or, you know, on the show and have fun? Eddie and Adam were the two kind of prodigal sons, you know, and they both followed each other after so many years of, will they come back? Well, you know, we're begging them like, please, do they know that they can come back? Or is there beef and blah, blah, blah? And then, you know, Adam did it in April
或者，你知道的，来节目里一起玩的？埃迪（Eddie）和亚当（Adam）是那两位所谓的浪子回头，你知道的，他们在经历多年关于“他们会不会回来”的猜测之后，先后回归了。好吧，你知道的，我们当时在苦求他们：“求求你们了，难道他们不知道他们可以回来吗？还是说有什么恩怨之类乱七八糟的？”然后，你知道的，亚当在四月份来了，
and Eddie did it at Christmas. And that was a hell of a year. Absolutely. But, you know, I'm still on the, you know, get Brad Pitt to come in there for real. Like he did that opening for us in the pandemic. Yeah. Yeah. That was cool.
埃迪在圣诞节来了。那可真是疯狂的一年。绝对的。不过，你知道的，我还是希望能把布拉德·皮特（Brad Pitt）弄来现场。就像他在疫情期间为我们做的那段开场一样。对。对。那太酷了。
That was great. He was playing Fauci. He's very funny. He should do it. But yeah, Tom Cruise, Will Smith, you know. Yeah. Yeah. Any of those guys that haven't done it that are on that level, like come on through.
太棒了。他当时在扮演福奇（Fauci）。他非常搞笑。他应该来做一次。不过，是的，汤姆·克鲁斯（Tom Cruise）、威尔·史密斯（Will Smith），你知道的。对。对。任何那些还没来过、达到那个级别的人，尽管来吧。
Do you speak, speaking of Keenan, like now that you're around all these like school teachers or whatever your kids have expanded your life, do you use that as inspiration for characters? Are you one that actually physically, actively seeks out kind of ideas for sketches and people to focus on? Or do you wait to work with a writer?
你有没有——说真的，基南，现在你周围都是这些学校老师或者你孩子带给你的各种生活体验，你会把这些当作角色的灵感来源吗？你是一个会身体力行、积极主动地为小品寻找构思和聚焦人物的人吗？还是说你会等着和编剧一起合作？
I do definitely pitch to writers because if I write by myself, it will not make any sense by page two and a half. I'm like, damn, that was quick. Like I went off course pretty quick. But you bring in like, oh my God, there's this teacher at my kid's school. I gotta do it.
我确实会向编剧提方案，因为如果我自己写，到了第二页半就会完全不知所云。我会想：“天哪，这进展得真快。”就像我很快就偏离轨道了一样。但当你带入这些元素，比如：“哦，天哪，我孩子学校里有这么个老师，我一定要演这个。”
1000%. Like I saw this, you know, thing or I witnessed my kids kind of, you know, having a conversation with an adult that's trying to help them. But all they want to talk about is what they want to talk about. So watching that conversation
1000%会这样。就像我看到了这个，你知道的，某件事，或者我亲眼目睹了我的孩子们，你知道的，在和试图帮助他们的大人对话。但他们只想谈论他们自己想谈论的事情。所以看着这种对话，
kind of just butt heads with each other is very funny. Now, will you walk around with a little black book in your pocket and write down ideas as they come to you throughout the day? It's the phone. I put notes on the phone. Oh, so you do that. Yeah, that's great.
彼此观点发生冲突，其实非常搞笑。那么，你平时会随身带着一个小黑本，把白天灵光一现的想法随时记下来吗？是手机。我在手机上记备忘录。哦，原来你这样做。对，这太棒了。
Yeah, I type them down because I learned, I don't know what I was watching, but it was like some movie about a comedian that was just like wake up in a panic and forget something that made him laugh so hard in his sleep. And he would forget to write it down and then he would like go try to remember it
对，我把它们打下来，因为我吸取了教训——我记不清当时在看什么了，但好像是一部关于某个喜剧演员的电影，他会从惊恐中醒来，然后忘掉了一个曾在睡梦中让他笑得前仰后合的笑话。他会忘了把它写下来，然后他会在表演的场合
in a performance setting and it wouldn't come to him or whatever. And I was like, oh shit, just write it down. Even if it's a quick two sentence thing to kind of remind you of that thought or whatever, it's so worth it because if I thought about, you know, the things that tickled me when nobody was looking and, you know, the fact that I can't remember them now,
试图去回忆它，却怎么也想不起来了。当时我就想：“哦，该死，把它写下来吧。”哪怕只是简短的两句话来提醒自己那个想法什么的，这也绝对值得，因为如果我想起那些曾让我独自发笑的事情，而我现在却记不起来了，
it makes me sad, you know, because I can't share those things with people. Or you feel like you don't have the ability to kind of self generate those things anyway. So when they do come to you, it's like, let me just write that down. So I don't, you know, leave it behind. I do hate that.
这会让我很难过，你知道吗，因为我无法与大家分享这些东西。或者你会觉得自己无论如何都没有能力凭空产生这些灵感。所以当它们真的找上门来时，就会变成：让我把它记下来。这样我就不会，你知道的，把它抛之脑后。我真的很讨厌这一点。
Why can't, why all of a sudden the second you wake up, your mind starts this really fast erasing thing where you cannot remember your dream and the more you try to hold onto it, it like squeezes out of your brain fingers or whatever. And it's, what is that? I don't know. I don't understand that.
为什么一醒来的那一秒钟，你的大脑就会启动这种超快速的擦拭程序，让你根本记不清自己的梦，而且你越是努力想抓住它，它就越是从你的脑海手指间挤出去，或者诸如此类的？那是什么？我不知道。我真不明白这个。
But I have. Well, you want to, you want to go ahead and chime in on that? I just, I just, I know I'm so exhausted from explaining like just basic stuff. My eight year old questions. Hey Papa, how's it going? When I'm with Jason, I always feel like Jason and I are like on a beach somewhere and I'm his dad
不过我有。好吧，你想借此机会插话吗？我只是——我只是，我知道我解释那些基本的事情已经筋疲力尽了。我八岁孩子的提问。嘿，爸爸，最近怎么样？每当我和杰森在一起时，我总觉得我和杰森好像在某个海滩上，我是他的爸爸，
and the moon is rising and he's like, Papa, exactly just like he said. Question 75 of today. Yes. Yes, young man. What would you like to know? Oh, Keenan, we've taken up too much of your time, where are you going?
月亮正在升起，然后他就会说：“爸爸”，完全就像他刚才那样。今天第75个问题。是的。是的，年轻的小伙子。你想知道什么？哦，基南，我们占用了你太多时间，你要去哪儿？
You were sweet and kind. And we love you. Lill's got a hard out. I got a very hard out. Yeah, my hard out as well. You are, you're the best. And I, you know what, Keen? I hope it's another 19 or 20 years
你真是甜美又善良。我们都很爱你。莉尔有硬性离场时间。我确实有很严苛的离场时间。对，我的硬场离场时间也到了。你真的是——你是最棒的。而且，你知道吗，基南？我希望是另外19年或20年，
plus that you're on the show. Can we make some news right now? Can you just commit to another 19? I've already committed up to 50, up to year 50 for the show. So, you know. Which is what, two years from now? 22.
甚至更久，你一直留在节目里。我们现在能搞点大新闻吗？你能承诺再干19年吗？我已经承诺干到50岁了，一直干到节目第50年。所以，你知道的。那是多久？从现在起两年后？22年。
I thought you said five zero. Yeah, no, 50, to year 50 of the show. Wow, awesome. The anniversary is coming up in a couple years. So, that's all I know as far as what they would like me to do. Me personally, I'll stay there forever. That's awesome. You know what I mean?
我还以为你刚才说的是数字“50”。对，不，是50，直到节目的第50个年头。哇，太棒了。几年后就要迎来周年纪念了。所以，这就是我知道的他们希望我做的事情。至于我个人，我会永远呆在那里。太棒了。你知道我的意思吗？
I'll turn into Lauren Michaels. Like, I would fucking love it. You know? Wow. You should run it. Yeah, why don't you run it? You're running it already. Yeah, exactly.
我会变成下一个洛恩·迈克尔斯（Lorne Michaels）。天哪，我他妈太乐意了。你知道吗？哇。你应该去掌管它。对，你为什么不来掌管？你其实已经在掌管了。对，没错。
I mean, there's much more qualified people that have been there and like really been in the rooms that could do it as well. But I feel like I should be like third on the list for sure. For sure. Yeah, at least. Well, you are now. Yeah.
我的意思是，还有很多更有资历的人曾经在那里，而且真正亲历过那些核心会议，他们也能做得很好。但我感觉我绝对应该排在名单的第三位。绝对的。是的，至少排第三。好吧，你现在就是了。对。
Official. That's right, that's right. Okay, pal, thank you so much. We love you very, very much. I wish I could hug all of you. Thank you so very much. It's good to see you. Please keep doing what you're doing.
官方认证。没错，没错。好了，老兄，非常感谢。我们非常非常爱你。我真希望我能拥抱你们所有人。非常感谢。很高兴见到你们。请继续做你们正在做的事。
I'm so proud to have you for you. And didn't you guys just get paid? No. No, no, no. It's all for fun. We said no. That's just headlines. We ended up saying no.
我为你取得的成就感到无比骄傲。你们刚才是不是刚拿了片酬？没有。不，不，不。这纯粹是为了好玩。我们拒绝了。那只是新闻头条。我们最后拒绝了。
Yeah, turn it down. Good job. Thank you. That's smart. Yeah. Amazing. Thank you, Kenan. Say hi to Atlanta.
对，拒绝了。干得好。谢谢。这很明智。对。太棒了。谢谢你，基南。替我向亚特兰大问好。
Thank you, man. I definitely will. I'm sorry, we'll see you in the playoffs there, Jason. Don't worry about it. Oh, there we go. It's okay. Hot dogs for everyone. Thanks for doing this, buddy.
谢谢你，老兄弟。我一定会的。抱歉，我们在季后赛见啦，杰森。别担心。哦，这就对了。没关系。人人都有热狗吃。谢谢你做这些，老兄。
Thanks, Kenan. So do I just leave? I'll just leave. Yes, you slam it. You can slam it shut. You can slam it shut. All right. Love you guys.
谢谢你，基南。那我直接走吗？我直接走就行。是的，你把它摔上。你可以把它摔上。你可以把它摔上。好了。爱你们。
Love you too, pal. Bye, buddy. Kenan Thompson is... One of the kindest guys. I love that guy. Yeah, I love him too. So funny. Tip top.
我也爱你，老兄。再见，兄弟。基南·汤普森是——最善良的家伙之一。我太喜欢这家伙了。是的，我也很喜欢他。太搞笑了。顶级。
He is that guy when you run in, well, first of all, when you see him in something, but when you run into him in person, he's always got a smile on his face and he's such a warm person. Yeah. And he just makes you feel good to see him. And yeah, and he's always chill.
他就是那种人，当你遇到——首先，当你在某些作品里看到他时，但当你本人偶遇他时，他脸上总是带着微笑，而且是个非常温暖的人。是的。看到他就让人感觉心情很好。而且，是的，他总是那么淡定。
He's like, he's always like very, doesn't get upset. Like, you know. And he's always funny. Like he's so reliable. Like in every, like he always shows up and it's just like Kenan's gonna be great. Everybody, this thing can fall apart. Kenan's gonna be great.
他就像是——总是非常从容，不会发脾气。就像，你知道的。而且他总是很好笑。他太靠谱了。就好像无论在什么情况下——他总是能交出完美的表现，大家心里都会想：“基南肯定会表现得很棒。”所有人，哪怕事情一团糟，基南也绝对能力挽狂澜。
That's right. What was the name of the show? Was it Kenan and Kel? Yeah. The Nickelodeon show way back when? Yeah. Did you watch it? Yeah.
没错。那个节目的名字叫什么来着？是《基南和基尔》（Kenan and Kel）吗？对。很久以前尼克国际儿童频道的节目？对。你看过吗？对。
Yeah, yeah, yeah. I used to love it. I liked it. Were you on it? Huh? Were you on it? I had three callbacks, but nope. Still waiting here.
对，对，对。我以前超爱看。我很喜欢。你上过那个节目吗？哈？你上过吗？我有过三次试镜复试，但是——没有。还在等消息呢。
I did not go my direction. That was before his time, man. That was before his time. Anyway, I love him. He's the greatest. And I'm so glad he was on. I did hear back from Jessica Meir during that. Sorry, still rolling.
没朝着我希望的方向发展。那在他那个年代之前了，老兄。那是他之前的年代了。不管怎样，我太爱他了。他是最棒的。我很高兴他能来。刚才我确实收到了杰西卡·梅尔（Jessica Meir）的回信。抱歉，还在录制中。
You can say that again. Just a little bit more sincerity and action. I love, I'm still. Your text is still gonna be there when you're done with the line and action. I'm so glad Kenan was on. He's just a really great guy. And I love him very much.
这话你完全可以再说一遍。只需要再多一点真诚和动作。我喜欢，我还在。等你演完这段台词，你的短信依然会在那里，然后——动作。我太高兴基南能来做节目了。他真的是个非常了不起的家伙。我非常喜欢他。
He's fantastic. OK, did you have something else you wanted to talk about? Let's just cut new slate. We'll just, we'll just. It's too long to read everything, but she says, ha, ha, ha, our PR contact just told me your assistant said the same thing. Good thing we clear that up.
他太棒了。好了，你还有什么想谈的事吗？我们直接切掉，换个新话题。我们就——我们就。要读的东西太多了，读不完，不过她说：“哈哈哈哈，我们的公关联系人刚刚告诉我，你的助理也说了同样的话。幸好我们把这事澄清了。”
And then she explained Florida and you sent to me. The difference is between Florida and Texas. Stop doing the fucking pose, bro. We're not, we're not in a Madonna video. Ew. A Madonna video. Yeah, doesn't he look like he's in a Madonna video with his dumb tan and his fucking terry?
然后她解释了佛罗里达州，而你发给我的是。佛罗里达和德克萨斯之间的区别。别再摆那种蠢姿势了，老兄。我们又不是在拍麦当娜的MV。呃。麦当娜的MV。是的，他不觉得他看起来就像在拍麦当娜的MV吗，顶着那个蠢透了的日晒妆，还穿着他那身该死的特里织物？
What's his face? Lighting. Richardson. Yep. Everybody's so tired because it's so late. I know it's so late. Well, it's late for us, not for Jason. Jason, though, you must have played early today, huh?
那家伙叫什么名字？灯光。理查森（Richardson）。对。每个人都累坏了，因为太晚了。我知道确实太晚了。好吧，对我们来说很晚，对杰森来说可不晚。不过杰森，你今天一定很早就开打了吧，哈？
Yeah, 8.30. I had to get it all out of my system before. Is it nice now? Yeah, it is nice now. Yeah. Sean, you've got something you want to say. I think you've got to lead up to something. Go ahead.
对，8点30分。我得在之前把精力都宣泄出来。现在感觉好点了吗？对，现在感觉好多了。对。肖恩，你有什么话想说。我觉得你正憋着什么话想说呢。说吧。
Yeah, I can see the sparkle in your eyes. I was just going to say when you guys, when you guys hit that ball, and you say, do you guys go four? Or do you guys say, bye? You've gotten so, so sloppy, so lazy. I can't do it. I have nothing. It's like watching season 16 of a TV show,
对，我能看到你眼里的闪光。我刚才只是想说，当你们——当你们击球的时候，你们会说“四”吗？还是你们会说“再见”？你们变得越来越敷衍，越来越懒散了。我接不下去了。我无话可说了。这感觉就像在看一部电视剧的第16季，
when everybody's just phoning it in. They're just reading their lines from their chair. But we'll allow it. That was a bye. Smart. Lass. Smart. Lass.
每个人都在敷衍了事。他们只是坐在椅子上照本宣科地念台词。不过我们允许你这么做。那算是一声再见。真聪明。俏皮话。
SmartLass is 100% organic and artisanally handcrafted by Bennett Barbicot, Michael Grant Terry, and Rob Armjurf. Smart. Lass. Our next episode will be out in a week, wherever you listen to podcasts, or you can listen to it right now, early on Amazon Music, or early and add free by subscribing to Wondery
SmartLass 100%有机，由班奈特·巴比科特（Bennett Barbicot）、迈克尔·格兰特·特里（Michael Grant Terry）和罗布·阿姆朱夫（Rob Armjurf）手工精制而成。Smart。Lass。我们的下一期节目将在一个星期后发布，你可以在任何收听播客的地方听到它，或者你也可以现在就在亚马逊音乐（Amazon Music）上提前收听，或者通过订阅苹果播客（Apple Podcasts）上的 Wondery Plus 或 Wondery App 来享受抢先收听和无广告体验。
Plus in Apple Podcasts, or the Wondery app. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
这期节目目前还没有评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可留下评论。